The cross-test between SCP-682 and SCP-173 with
high precision blades was a complete disaster.
Organized by Dr. Shenron, the two iconic
monsters were brought into a test chamber
and the blades were deployed,
cutting both of them into pieces.
Two D-Classes were sent in
when the vacuum system failed,
and were killed by SCP-682’s blobs of
flesh, and the newly reformed SCP-173.
At this point, the battle began, and 173
attacked the different blobs of 682 flesh.
Some blobs fought back, while others reformed into
a smaller version of 682, which stared at 173.
Just like in the original test, a sniper
shot out the eyes of this smaller 682,
leading 173 to snap its neck. It then
regenerated and stared at 173 for
seventeen hours before the test was finally
ended. When 173 was taken back to its cell,
there was a power failure in the hallway, leading
to a site-wide containment breach and many deaths.
Dr. Shenron’s troubleshooting with
the incinerator system was seen as
the catalyst for this deadly power failure, and
he was relieved from duty shortly afterwards.